he becomes prime minister
tomorrow how much of a risk is this if
you think back to when labor was elected
in 1997 obviously uh Devolution was a
big big constitutional reform that they
enacted it was specifically designed to
keep the SMP out of power and it's
actually had the opposite effect is
there a risk
oh here we go well we're gonna we'll
have to leave that question we'll come
back to that one Gordon Brown's about to
speak it's a real pleasure to be at this
great University to be in Leeds and to
be back in Yorkshire
and it's a real privilege to be the
warm-up speaker
for the leader best equipped best
qualified be the to be the next prime
minister of the United Kingdom kirst
armor
the leader
the leader that will take this country
into the future and it's also a pleasure
to give a vote of thanks to Tracy Robin
whose spectacular success in just 18
months as mayor proves the central case
that our commission is making today for
the biggest transfer of power out of
Westminster and Whitehall to the
localities and it's the biggest transfer
of power that our country has seen
now today's report is not a one-man
report it is a 12-member commission
report and I want to thank the members
of the commission sitting in the front
row here for all the work they have done
representing every region and every
nation of our country thank you very
much for what you've done
for today what labor is doing
we are ditching A Century of
centralization we are calling a halt to
the over centralization of power at the
center that has brought us conservative
sleaze and conservative Scandal and
we're ending the long era of the man in
Whitehall somehow knowing best
now start from our faith that instead of
developing some of the potential of only
some of the people in some areas of the
country we can create a United Kingdom
that develops all of the potential of
all people in all areas of the country
and identified in our report are 288 New
Economic clusters 200 of them outside
London in digital environmental life
science Advanced manufacturing and
creative Industries these are the future
engines of growth they cover every city
and every region they are employment
hotspots capable of creating tens of
thousands of new high-paying jobs around
our country
and we show today how Mayors and Local
Economic Partnerships and local
authorities can create the supportive
local environment and so first of all to
link the jobs people need to the
companies who need them we propose 638
job centers transferred from inflexible
central control down to local control to
match local skills to local employment
needs the Devolution of 200 colleges of
Education to local control to finance
research and investment urgently needed
across this country and to bridge the
regional Equity Gap facing growing firms
the British Business Bank will be
transformed into the British national
and Regional Bank and to build Regional
transport and infrastructure we propose
joint ventures with the European
Investment Bank
but to secure the irreversible transfer
of wealth income and opportunity that we
want to see we also need an irreversible
transfer of power
past Devolution settlements as Tracy has
just described have left the center
unreformed
so to ensure the right powers are in the
right places we must first stop the
wrong Powers being wielded by the wrong
people in the wrong places
and so the New Britain needs a new
Westminster and we need a new Whitehall
in recent years as you all know an
unreformed Center has been exposed as
out of date out of touch with local
needs out of its debts when it tries to
micromanage local events and all too
often out of control conflicts of
interest the misuse of power the abusive
patronage ethics so unacceptable that
this government has lost all its recent
ethics advisors
so we've not just the change who makes
the decisions we've got to change the
way decisions are made now the starting
point of cleaning up our politics is
setting forward a mission statement of
what the United Kingdom is for these are
our obligations to each other to deliver
free Universal Health Care and poverty
build a sustainable environment have
strong defense and guaranteed security
and with that are new rules so that
public servants will always serve the
public enforced by an anti-corruption
agency that we propose to investigate
wrongdoing Guided by an integrity and
ethics commission as proposed by Angela
Rayner for day-to-day monitoring of
standards in public life and so that it
is clear that the era of self-regulation
at the center is over a citizen's jury
representing the public undertaking a
regular review of standards in public
life backed up by a ban on All Foreign
funding of British politics and an end
to MP's second jobs
so we need to clean up but we also need
to clear out
fifty thousand civil servants
transferred out of London to save 200
million pounds and the first 12 of many
agencies that are also candidates of
dispersal to save millions of pounds
more to the benefit of all the proposals
that Rachel Reeves is making the
replacement of the indefensible
830 member House of laws with a smaller
Democratic second chamber which will be
an assembly of the Nations and regions
that would lose its right to delay
ordinary legislation for a year but
assume a new function to protect the
Constitution our message is
opportunities for all unfair privileges
for No One and to ensure we work
together in future we're going to end
the standoff between local and National
politics with a new Council of the
United Kingdom chaired by the prime
minister to examine issues of common
concern to all parts of the country
now in 2016 the British people were
promised they would take back control
but it's not the people but the old
conservative establishment that took
back control and millions of people both
leave and remain voters still feel
neglected ignored forgotten invisible to
the person be and often left with the
feeling that they're being treated as
second-class Citizens
so as we make clear labor is not the old
establishment in waiting it is a new
government in Waiting ready to transform
Britain
now after years of moving apart
Devolution in Scotland Northern Ireland
and Wales and then centralization in
England we are now all talking about
empowering local communities
and with a detailed plan to make the UK
work for Scotland and Wales as well as
for the regions we tell both yes and no
voters that we can reunite the country
the issue now is no longer Independence
versus the status quo in Scotland but
change within the UK to benefit Scotland
versus change by leaving the UK which
would do damage to Scotland and so I
believe today we can give people hope
removing the Dead Hand of centralization
we are proposing that there will be a
government not just off the people and
for the people but a government by the
people for there is a basic truth upon
which we build all the recommendations
of our report that you will see in
detail today and again I want to thank
all members of the commission for the
work they have done wherever you go in
Britain there is Talent yet to be
developed ability still to be realized
endless potential waiting to be
fulfilled and conscious of this huge gap
today between the Britain we have and
the Britain we have it in our power to
become I look forward to a New Britain
where there is equality and opportunity
and fairness in outcome and New Britain
led by the labor party a New Britain led
by KIA stammer whom I introduce to you
now thank you very much
[Applause]
foreign
thank you Gordon and thanks to all of
you for coming this morning I can see so
many faces here it's fantastic to be
back at Leeds University where I spent
three happy years and thank you to the
commission members who've joined us this
morning as well
and thank you Tracy you're doing an
incredible job here in West Yorkshire
protecting the safety of women and girls
cheaper and better buses making this
region a hub of green industry
but I know that you could do so much
more
I know that businesses here people here
communities here could do so much more
but you're being held back
held back by A system that holds power
in Westminster
a system which smugly things
it knows what skills transport planning
a job support West Yorkshire needs
better than the people who live here
I've long been convinced that this
broken model has held back our politics
and held back our economy and I'm
determined we unbind ourselves
and free our potential
Britain is one of the most centralized
systems in Europe and the center has not
delivered
now I don't want it to fall apart I want
us to build something new
anyone can see what's happening in the
UK today
we have an unbalanced economy
one which makes too little use of the
talents of too few people in too few
places
and which the tourists have dragged into
a vicious cycle of low growth and high
taxes
faced with this narrow path of
stagnation
is it any surprise that people up and
down the country are crying out for a
new approach
now during the brexit referendum I
argued for remain
but I couldn't disagree with the basic
case that lots of lead voters made to me
they wanted more control over their
lives
more control over their country they
wanted to create opportunities for the
Next Generation build communities they
felt proud of have public services they
could rely on
but I know that in the Scottish
referendum in 2014
many of those who voted yes
did so for similar reasons the same
frustrations at a Westminster system
that seems remote
the same yearning for the chance to
build a fairer future for themselves and
their families
people know Britain needs change
but they're never going to get it from
the Tories who talk about leveling up
fuse to move power away from Westminster
who once promised a stronger Union but
can't work with or for Scotland
and who think that the only route to
Prosperity is to make the rich richer
and hope that somehow it trickles down
to everyone else
to build the future our country deserves
means change
it means higher standards in public life
a wider spread of power and opportunity
and better economic growth that benefits
everyone wherever they are
no more Naval gazing or facing inwards
higher wider better
that is how Britain must set its size
and I'm determined that with labor
that's exactly what we will do
that's why I asked Gordon and the
commission to carry out a report of the
future of the UK
I asked them to put together a proposal
for the biggest ever transfer of power
from Westminster to the British people
so that if labor wins the next election
Britain will see a change not just in
who governs
but how we are governed
the tools to a fairer society and a
stronger economy placed directly in the
hands of working people
so together we can build an economy not
just for the many
but by the many and of the many
now redistribution is a good thing
but it's not a one-word plan for a fair
Society or a strong economy
by empowering our towns cities regions
and Nations to work together on local
growth plans labor will reignite our
economy
new powers over skills transport
planning and culture all helping to
drive growth by developing hundreds of
clusters of economic activity
labor will rebuild Trust by reforming
the center of government
cleaning up slaves nourishing the
relationship between central government
and the devolved authorities
and replacing the unelected House of
Lords with a new smaller democratically
elected second chamber
not only less expensive
but also representing the regions and
nations of the United Kingdom
and labor will reunite our country with
New Missions based on our shared values
and priorities cooperating to tackle
climate change and addressing inequality
giving Scotland Wales Northern Ireland
and the regions of England new status
and louder prouder voices in a reformed
and modern United Kingdom
I want to thank Gordon and the
commission for their work
they've put forward a compelling vision
of how we can break Britain's economic
and political malaise how we can restore
trust to British politics
how we can offer a fairer Greener future
to the whole of our United Kingdom
that vision is underpinned by serious
and bold recommendations
and these will now be a matter of public
consultation
so they can be tested refined and made
ready for implementation
we will set out our final plans in our
Manifesto
and I invite everyone who wants to build
that fair or Greener future to get
involved
whether you voted leave or remain
yes or no
live in a city or town we will make
common cause with you
together we will Forge something bold
something modern something hopeful
together we will build a better future
thank you
foreign
we're now going to take some questions
from the media and I know it's been a
race uh with the trains to see who
arrived at what order they arrived but
I'm going to do my best on who I know
and think is here Beth from Skye can we
take you first I can see you've arrived
safely just about got here
okay Stormer at a time when people are
struggling to pay their bills feed their
families in a striking overpay
settlements you've produced a
155-page report talking about Devolution
constitutional reform and abolishing the
House of Lords this might look to many
people as completely out of touch and
you could look like another politician
talking to Westminster about stuff that
might never come to pass can you give me
one thing in this report that would
improve people's lives from day one of a
labor government
and if I made to Gordon Brown
Nicholas sturgeon has declared the next
election of de facto Independence
referendum you talk about father
Devolution but hasn't the horse already
bolted and do you accept that Scotland
could become an independent nation in
your lifetime or mine thank you Beth the
complete opposite of the proposition you
put to me this is vitally important if
we ask ourselves in this room across the
country what is the single biggest thing
that's holding us back it's failure of
economic growth over the last 12 years I
profoundly believe that amongst the
causes for that is because we have not
allowed and empowered every part of our
country to play its part in building our
economy we've allowed we've relied far
too much on London and the southeast we
have not let the whole country play its
part this addresses that question and I
can tell you wherever I am across the
country whether it's Burnley whole black
ball Sterling Sunderland Southampton
everybody I meet and so did my shadow
cabinet they meet communities and
businesses and people that say we've got
ideas we've got Innovation we want our
community and our place to be even
better than it is we just need a
government that shares our ambition
shares our vision for the future so this
could not be more relevant and you know
I'm fed up to the back teeth with
sticking plasters for the problems that
we've got the underlying problem is our
economy isn't working this is a strong
compelling set of recommendations that
do what politicians have all agreed
needs to be done but nobody's actually
done it which is to be bold enough to
say that we've got to stop those in
Westminster and Whitehall pretending
that they know best about the
communities that desperately want to
play their part in the future we're
going to transfer that power to them
rebuild our economy and I don't think
this is the complete opposite of a
discussion Westminster it's accepting
that Westminster is not the place for
those decisions to be made they've got
to be made elsewhere Gordon can I bring
you in on the second element of that
just as in 2016 a lot of people voted
for brexit because they thought that was
their only chance of change
in 2014 a lot of people voted for
Independence because they thought that
was the only change on offer we are
changing that entirely today we are
breaking new ground the ground on which
the battle is fought in Scotland is
changing forever because what we are
saying is we are offering change within
the UK that will benefit Scotland as
against change by leaving the United
Kingdom which we think will do damage to
Scotland and that's going to be the
debate from now on in not change and not
Independence versus the status quo but
change within Britain versus change by
leaving Britain and the measures of
course we're putting forward to give
more power to Scotland and to Wales and
to the regions and localities and
communities of England all go hand in
hand and are in the same direction
together
so when you come to the next election it
may be that the Scottish national party
will have a one-line Manifesto and want
a one-issue general election but I tell
you this we have done a huge amount of
research on Scottish public opinion and
people want a Better Health Service
immediately people want living standards
improved immediately people want jobs
for young people immediately people want
better housing immediately and people of
course want change in the way that we
are suggesting immediately and that's
going to be the issue in which we fought
we fight we are offering a plan for
economic social political and
constitutional reform not a one issue
election thank you
just if I may be a bit cheeky and ask us
a quick follow-up I asked you one which
policy in this report from day one will
change people's lives because it's so
amorphous what's the one thing that
you're gonna do the most important thing
in that report that will change all of
our Lives evolving power in relation to
skills education transport resources
finances into our local communities so
that they can help us grow the economy
there are so many examples of this
you've got video games in Dundee you've
got Ceramics in the Midlands you've got
Creative Media in Bristol and bath
hydrogen could be what the Northeast
revitalizes around there are so many
examples I think we've got 288 economic
clusters if we were able to transfer
power in this way and get those clusters
to operate it will bring about a huge
change everywhere including here in
Leeds that would if we were to turn
around our economy will begin to turn
around our economy have a massive all
these issues about the cost of living
and the strikes all the things you ask
us every day have one common cause and
that is our economy is not working for
everyone in this country it is the
mission of the next Labor government to
fight the election on that issue to win
it and to bring about the change that we
desperately desperately need in this
country Chris
Mason from BBC News let's talk about
specifics Kia summer how much of this do
you actually want to deliver rather than
just talk about and on one of the issues
do you promise to get rid of the House
of Lords within a first term of a labor
government and what do you say to those
who are struggling to pay bills at the
moment who are worried about the strikes
coming up who hear this this morning and
just think it's a bit high-minded and
academic
yeah Chris on the
um implementation
I I asked for this work to be done
because I fundamentally believe this is
the change we need to bring about in our
country and therefore it will be the
driving mission of the next Labor
government we now arrive with the report
and with recommendations and when we set
up the commission Gordon and I talked
about the terms of reference and in the
report itself that I wanted and the
report delivers recommendations capable
of it being implemented within the first
five years of a labor government so very
clear about that we will now have a
period of consultation to refine to test
but also to make sure that we can answer
the question when and how are you going
to implement and if you're going to make
such a big transfer of power away from
Whitehall
to lots of places across the country
then we obviously need to have that
discussion about how is that going to be
done because this is not going to be a
talking shop the reason we're doing the
consultation now between now and
drafting the manifesto and before the
election is I don't want to do the
talking afterwards so we're not going to
be Consulting when we're in power we're
going to be delivering and we will be
delivering what is in these
recommendations obviously there's a
discussion about how unprecisely when
but my driving mission is to deliver I
want the first five years of the labor
government to be a delivery exercise I
want as much of this delivered as
possible and therefore that consultation
is about delivering and that's all
recommendations to be delivered as
quickly as possible because we're not
going to be Consulting after that
Manifesto but that's why we asked for
recommendations that we're capable of
being delivered within the first five
years of a labor government so I'm very
clear that we're not putting this off I
don't want a discussion Etc going on for
years on end I want to see the change
because I think the change not just
economically which I was concentrating
on in Beth's case but also politically
um you know the the the so many people
in this country feel they are not being
heard they can't influence the the
decisions the other people suggest that
they know better about the things that
are local to them and we need to break
that model and to break it for good so
we want to get on to deliver this and
that means but this is a first term
agenda can I on your second Point um
Chris look whenever any politician sets
out an answer to the underlying issue
the medium and long term every
journalist says but I want an answer to
what's going to happen the next few
weeks and we go on and on and on we've
been doing this for 12 years what are
you going to do about the NHS winter
crisis well we need more people in HS
don't want that answer it'll take too
long tell me what you do this winter and
then we go on spin forward 12 months
next question what do you do about the
NHS we need more people don't want that
out so that's medium term what are you
going to do this winter same on energy
what are you gonna do on energy we need
new Renewables don't want that answer it
takes too long what are you gonna do
this winter same on what are you gonna
do about the economy we've got to
fundamentally change it to make sure it
works for everyone I don't want that
answer tell me what to do this winter we
will go on with this sticking cluster
approach forever we've been doing it for
12 years it's one of the reasons we
haven't got anywhere so I'm not going to
shy away Gordon is right we do need to
answer what are we going to do about
energy prices we've actually answered
that question took a lead to say freeze
Energy prices use the excess profits of
oil and gas companies to pay for that
Etc we've answered the question about
what are you going to do with the NHS by
saying
what we'll do immediately what we'll do
in the longer term but we can't keep
shying away from this or pretending and
actually Chris I reckon if you spent you
know some time in Leeds today I don't
mean this patronizing don't get me wrong
but talk you know people here have got a
passion for this change
and I were in Burnley not so long ago
people want this change they've been
saying it for a long time they just want
a government that gets it and gets on
with it so
um you know this is absolutely Central
to answering the everyday questions and
issues that people are facing and less
of the sticking plaster more of the
actual solutions to the problem and to
be honest there's a political consensus
that we need to move decision making
from from Whitehall out to closer to
people but only labors come up with a
compelling comprehensive case for
actually doing so and I'm very proud
that we've done that thank you Chris
I've got Nick from the telegraph
please
thank you
um 76 labor MPS have second jobs would
you lead by example by telling them that
they need to give those up and would you
have any plans to introduce an internal
party ban on on second jobs ahead of the
next election and if I may quickly one
on strikes you've previously said that
you would repeal all anti-union
legislation can you commit to repealing
any legislation the conservatives pass
on minimum service levels and when would
you do that would be a priority as soon
as you enter office thank you yeah look
called second jobs Nick there are
proposals in the report as you will have
seen and obviously they will be
consulted on just as we'll consult on
the other issues but actually I think
it's a year or so ago we already set out
our position in relation to Second jobs
when this first cropped up I was in the
middle of a press conference when
um Boris Johnson tried to bomb my press
conference by by proposing the very same
thing in relation to Second jobs the
difference is he hasn't gone on with it
so we've set that out there are
proposals in clear terms in the report
now there is obviously again a question
of how we Implement those but we've
actually set out a pretty compelling
case on second jobs on the question of
where the government goes next on
strikes look I don't think more
legislation restricting the right to
strike is the Right Way Forward I think
the government should fix the underlying
problems I think the government should
get off its hands and it's been sitting
on its hands throughout these disputes
rather than resolving them and you don't
have to go far go to Wales and see a
different government taking a different
approach and some of the not dissimilar
disputes have actually been resolved and
I think that's you know there's resolved
the issues now but you know what's what
underpins this these industrial disputes
it's a cost of living crisis which is
pressured down on people because the
economy isn't working and so it's not
you know that the report today is not
removed from the question of what you do
on strike and Industrial action it
actually underpins it thank you Nick
I've got Ashley from the mirror
[Applause]
proposals that you've outlined today are
probably going to take a number of years
would you commit to abolishing the
heretic repair position in the House of
Lords within the first few weeks of
taking office I mean surely there's no
need for a consultation on that issue
and are you committed to having this new
chamber in Westminster or will be will
it be another city like Leeds where we
are today
um on her entry peers I mean the sooner
we can abolish them the better I think
the last Labor government went further
than any previous government down that
road and I'd be surprised if there's
anybody that could make a halfway
sensible argument for hereditary peers
so of course that needs to be done but
you know what I would say Ashley is the
House of Lords reforms within this
report are really important but they've
got to be seen as part of the much wider
package of devolution of power away from
Westminster and Whitehall two
communities both politically and
economically and that's the driving
issue that goes through this report that
was the central thing that I wanted
answered the House of Lords reform is
part of that because I don't think you
can have a serious discussion about the
future of the UK without addressing the
House of Lords which is not capable of
being defended in my view
on the location of any second chamber
look the report doesn't make any
recommendations in relation to that I
think the discussion is much more likely
to be what's the makeup Etc but one of
the important things about place and one
of the recommendations in the report
you'll have seen is that
the second chamber should have
representatives from Scotland Wales
Northern Ireland and from the regions
now that's not to create new posts it's
to make use of what we've got and I
think that is very very important hard
wiring a stronger voice for Scotland and
Wales and for our regions now mayors in
the arrangements that we'll put in place
through a second chamber thank you
Ashley
um Jen from the financial times I'm
hoping has made it
yes
um just on the Council of Nations and
regions there seemed to be a few
different versions possible versions of
that in the report I think there's a
council of England a council of the UK
Council of Nations and regions I just
wondered what your
personally what your preference should
be what would that look like in practice
this is this is on the the body that
would be like a concealed
um
a body that that would draw together
different parts of the country to
consult
yeah I mean I'll bring Gordon in um on
this but just to be clear they're not
Alternatives they work differently so
the council for the regions and Nations
brings together the representatives of
the regions and Nations
um the counts of the Nations is
effectively to take over from a giant
ministerial Group which didn't work very
well and the Council of England is to
deal with regional representation in
England so they're not Alternatives
they're these are not new politicians
that we're inventing by the way they're
not newly elected posts or anything but
they're making much better use of the
representatives that we already have
Gordon just to make sure Jen that we've
got the complete answer to your question
just think of the first stages of the
virus and what was happening with covert
where every local Authority the Mayors
at Scotland Wales and Northern Ireland
were complaining that there was not
proper consultation about some of the
measures that were being taken that
there were different interpretation
Nations being given and there ought to
be some form of coordination and what
we're really saying is whether it's that
or whether it's dealing with the
environment or whether it's dealing with
some of the economic issues that come up
we should have the ability and capacity
for all the key players to meet together
at a council chaired by the Prime
Minister and that would be uh Kia
stammer in my view and my hope and with
an independent secretary to bring
together the agendas of the different uh
bodies that make this up so the Council
of the UK would be the Scotland Wales
Northern Ireland and the UK government
that it would sometimes meet as the
Council of the Nations and regions with
the different regions of England that
would have been far more relevant when
we were dealing with covid but sometimes
there's just distinctly English
legislation and it would meet as a
council to look at English legislation
or English practices and procedures so
it's really one council with three
different forms of of meeting chaired by
the Prime Minister what what the Welsh
first Minister mark Drakeford you may
remember complained that he'd written to
the Prime Minister Boris Johnson at the
start of covert and he hadn't even had a
written reply now these are the things
that should not happen if the United
Kingdom is going to work well and is
going to work together we need to have a
form of consultation and coordination
and that's what the commission and the
commission was made up of every region
and nation and you can talk to all the
members who are here today that's what
we recommend and I think it's the only
way forward for Britain Great thank you
quickly ask a follow-up question that
that's set the trend everybody you um if
you win the next election you'll have
been out of power 13 40 years by that
point are you really going to hand power
away is the first thing that you do yes
I think it's absolutely vital
but I don't see it as handing power away
if it's putting power where it should be
and I think that's very very important
to say because we're only going to
repair our economy repair our politics
if we recognize that decisions about
communities and places are best made by
those with skin in the game so it's not
about whether we're giving our power
away it's recognizing where power
properly should be I've got Amy from
Global radio I hope
hi yes thank you very much and so
improving Rail and transport links in
the north is the key to the evolution if
you were to become Prime Minister what's
the first thing you would do to make our
trams buses and trains better
well firstly keep our promises put the
resource in and also give more power
to those in the locality to make key
decisions I feel very strongly about
this in relation to buses because we all
talk about trains a lot and for good
reason not least this morning
um but actually the vast majority of
people or many more people go to work
get around on buses and what you've seen
with our Metro Mayors is the shaping of
the future of our buses in relation to
fixed prices so that people can actually
afford and some control over the roots
so you don't just get buses hundreds of
buses going on the most profitable route
and no buses going to the route that you
know maybe isn't the most profitable so
there are key things we could do
straight away I do want to bring Tracy
in on this because I've been on one of
Tracy's buses here in Leeds not long ago
and it would only be right that she
brings in to say what she's doing on
buses which is Greening buses but also
the ambition in relation to prices and
route thank you um and thank you Jen for
your work focusing on buses and trains
and making it really important look we
all know that the uh particularly in the
north at the train network is broken but
80 of those on public transport travel
by bus it's really important in a cost
of living crisis to reduce the fares now
I've been able to do that but I don't
have control over the networks so while
I've been reducing fares I have
companies running for profit that are
pulling out routes so people are saying
to me oh it's all right Tracy a cheap
Affair but there's no boss for me to get
on so I don't have those powers and that
control and when corralling the northern
Mayors to talk to the transport Minister
we represent nine million people and our
boss on our train network is broken our
boss network is run for profit this is
not good enough and that's why I am so
delighted to be here today because For
the First Time it really feels like we
are being heard particularly in the
north that we don't have to go cap in
hand to government time and again
because when we get a labor government
we'll have colleagues who understand
that if you give power to those who
understand their communities and what
needs to be done then we can bring that
change and that economic recovery for
the whole of the country buses are
really important and it seems like I am
the boss Queen now so um I do travel on
buses actually and again the other day
said hey Tracy a gay kid I've voted for
you because you're one of us and I think
people in power also need to live like
the people that they represent as well
so I think it's a good that you brought
it up thanks Jen
thank you Amy
um focusing on Yorkshire again you talk
about developing clusters of economic
activity how will these um how will this
affect Yorkshire what will happen here
oh well I mean um Tracy can come in on
this as well but Leeds
um you know Health Tech fintech that
leads us got really good hubs here
already that we can build on a build out
to other places across Yorkshire
um and Beyond
um and what that gives is
um the ability the rightful ability for
communities businesses Partnerships to
help us grow the economy starting in
their place and also giving an identity
to place
um you know whether it's Health Tech
here fintech here or whether it's
hydrogen on the Northeast Coast
not only growth but the economic place
and identity as well because you know
there are different theories of economic
growth one Theory says you could grow
more in London and the southeast and
then redistribute to the rest of the
United Kingdom I profoundly disagree
with that theory of growth and a labor
government won't go down that theory of
growth because I don't think it respects
and uses the resource and talent and
Brilliance of everybody else across the
whole of the United Kingdom which is why
we want these recommendations to drive
through growth in every part of the
United Kingdom and stop this system that
holds back communities everywhere you
don't need to go very far into any
Community either here in Yorkshire
across the rest of the country and you
will meet people with massive ambition
about what they could do where they are
they just haven't got a government
that's up alongside them are going to
change that
now Mason from the Yorkshire post Mason
uh thank you um in terms of specifics of
how this is actually going to work for
Yorkshire um a one Yorkshire Devolution
deal is something that's very popular
um in your own party and in the region
is this something that you're ruling out
in the consultation because it sounds
like you are when you say you don't want
to redraw any boundaries or take Powers
away from existing Mayors and areas
I'll bring Tracy in on this
what I don't want to do is use the
commission as the place in which we have
an argument about boundaries for or
numerals Etc et cetera it doesn't mean
that forever I'm committed to never
changing any of that but it is important
we could have a long discussion about
which mayor or what whether there should
be a mayor for this place that place
what powers they should have let's align
all the powers and it is a you know
because of the way it's developed there
are differences and there are places
that do or don't have different types of
representation so you could have quite
an interesting academic discussion for
five years about precisely how you
change all of that but that isn't how I
want to run a labor government I want a
labor government that says we are where
we are let's start with the powers we
know are already there combined
authorities Metro Mayors Mayors other
clusters and let's build our economy
from there I think we can have a
discussion about other issues and
boundaries at the same time but I do
know that if we go down the rabbit
Warren of just talking about where the
boundaries are we'll come out in five
years time without actually having
changed anything for people in the areas
they live in and we're not going to do
that under a labor government thank you
very much
then I've got Kate from ITV Yorkshire I
hope
thank you um yeah there are many people
in Yorkshire who've already welcomed
this notion of more Powers but with that
has to come more money to implement
significant changes where particularly
at this time where on Earth is that
going to come from well
um Katie what we want to do is to make
sure that Resource as well as power
comes out of Westminster and Whitehall
and that does mean control over the
money as well as the decision making
there are a number of different ways
that could be done they're set out in
the report including the fact that quite
a lot of money at the moment is in silos
and therefore there's no sort of
horizontal thing about how you can join
money up and they're controlled in the
center and therefore you know you could
almost sum up the government's leveling
up project as you know sitting in London
with a pot of money inviting people to
bid in to the pot and then to decide
along government lines who's going to
get any money I think that's completely
wrong we've got to be brave enough to
put the money there as well Gordon did
you want to come in on that no I think I
think you've summed it up to be honest
and then Gemma from Radio leads
yes
thank you
um when it comes to the extra powers for
Mayors like Tracy braben and Oliver
copard what exactly are we talking about
and also when it comes to these economic
clusters are you not sort of encouraging
mares and region sort of pitted against
each other chasing that investment
um
Gemma in terms of what would be devolved
what would the power that we're seeking
to transfer all of that is set out in
terms in the report but it's controlled
not just over resource it's control over
housing better control over transport
better control over skills better
control over further education there's
plenty in the report of examples of
where we feel the decision should be
made closer to where people are and
that's why it's a real that's why we
build it as the single biggest transfer
of power away from the center to the
places where decisions I feel ought to
be made on your second point about
competition quite the opposite
hardwired into this report is the word
cooperation and different areas
cooperating with each other I think
that's what happens in the real world I
think that's the way
um that you know I I came to the
Yorkshire post fastest 500 100 Awards
two or three years ago and I was really
struck by the 50 fastest story growing
country businesses in Yorkshire all
different businesses all doing different
things but actually able to complement
and work with each other and I think
there are examples that across the whole
of the United Kingdom so cooperation is
hardwired
you know I think the sooner we can go
down this path the sooner we can
actually start
um delivering it is the complete
opposite of a pot of money being held in
the center where the government says you
tell me why you should have that money
and I'll decide and I'll pit you against
each other you bet I will
um and you know this is the complete
inversion of that if you like if I could
just add that here I I think I want to
emphasize that when we were doing our
work we were looking at the economy of
the whole of the United Kingdom and how
it was changing and we were finding that
in different areas around the United
Kingdom including in Leeds right across
Yorkshire but right across the different
parts of the country there were new
Innovative companies new technologies
being developed sometimes out of the
universities sometimes out of bigger
companies becoming smaller smaller
companies come out of video companies
but needing support and they needed
support at the local level they needed
support to meet their training needs and
the skills that they wanted they needed
support with research and development
they needed support with infrastructure
transport and all these Arrangements
being suitable for them and this is not
happening at the moment in the way it
should and at the level that it should
so we identified 288 at different hubs
of economic activity around the United
Kingdom and we thought if the mayors and
the Local Economic Partnerships could
have the powers to develop the training
the skills and also to back them up with
research investment and infrastructure
then they would be in a far better
position to expand and create the jobs
of the future now if we'd been talking
20 or 30 years ago we might even talk
about British steel British coal British
Telecom britishness as the big creators
of jobs we're actually talking about
Innovative Industries in every part of
the country in the new technologies
digital creative also in life science
Sciences in medicine where the enormous
potential for breakthrough and Britain
to be one of the world leaders coming
not out of London but out of all the
different parts of the United Kingdom
and the report is really built around
this idea if you support these
industries and you support the new jobs
of the future then we can have a far
more successful economy Which is far
more balanced between north and south
and will create the big jobs of the
future and all our constitutional as
well as economic proposals are built
around this idea that there is huge
Ingenuity creativity and potential in
Britain that really is waiting to be
developed and it will have to be a labor
government under kyostama that does so
because it's not happening in the way it
should at the moment thank you Gordon I
I think darshana and robley are now here
I was told as I was waiting to come up
that there's a problem with the trains
but I think we now have you both so um
can we take um romley if you don't mind
first and then tashana or the other way
around yeah apologies for missing the
other questions I feel like I should ask
whether you can make the trains run on
time
but I will ask these are just
recommendations which you will now
consult on how many of them do you
expect and do you want to go into your
Manifesto and you expect to implement
the notoriously difficult House of Lords
reform in your first term yeah Romney
thank you for that it has come up but
it's still you know a very important
question so
um I asked for this report for this
commission to be set up for this report
to be prepared and I'm really pleased
with the recommendations that we've got
it's true that there will now be a
consultation on refining and testing and
how we Implement them but I made it
clear to Gordon and commission when we
started and it's within the report that
we wanted recommendations capable of
being implemented within the first five
years of a labor government and the
reason we're doing the consultation now
and before the election is because when
we come into power if we do and I hope
that we do we want to move straight to
implementing them as quickly as possible
that obviously includes the House of
Lords which is only one of a broad
number of recommendations but the what I
want is a labor government that delivers
I don't want a labor government that
carries on the discussion or the
consultation exercise we want to be in
delivering and that's why these
recommendations are deliberately couched
as actionable deliverable foundations
and why we made it clear from the start
that we wanted recommendations capable
of delivery within that first five-year
term of a labor government and deshana
we've been interviewing people out and
about over the last few months people
who are really struggling with their
bills cost of living you know employment
their wages and so on none of them
mentioned things like House of Lords
reform I'm wondering if you feel that
this is a priority for people at the
minute well the house law reform is one
of a huge number of recommendations
what's driving the report what drives me
and what will drive the next Labor
government is fixing our broken economy
and fixing our broken politics and this
report is Central to that of course we
all know there's a cost of living crisis
of course we all know that energy prices
are too high of course we all know that
the NHS is already in a winter crisis
but underpinning all of that is 12 years
of failure when it comes to the economy
12 years of failure to grow the economy
but any significant rate and we've got
to fix that and I genuinely believe that
holding us back is the fact that we
don't use all the parts of our United
Kingdom to help grow our economy that
too much Reliance is on London and the
southeast and this is not about putting
down London or the southeast it's about
empowering the other parts of the
country so and I
genuinely believe not just because
um you know I'm saying it theoretically
I and My Shadow cabinet spend our whole
time out of London across the country in
different communities the most it's much
more useful being in Parliament half the
time and everywhere I go it's the same
leads or wherever it is it's the same
story ask any Community whether they've
got ideas Ambitions for where they are
where they live and the change that they
think could be brought about you bet
they have there's no shortage if you
know if you take your crew out come with
us on one of our sessions where we ask
people what are your answers
well there we are we're going to grab a
word with Scotty's political editor Beth
Rigby who's been watching this event in
Leeds for the last hour Beth has your
pulse been racing at all of that
so
Ian so it's hard to you because care
Stone was just wrapping up uh this press
conference here in Leeds what are they
doing it's 155 page report about the
UK's future and it's all about to quote
the party leader about devolving power
from Westminster from fixing to quote
him our broken economy and our broken
politics it's a report commissioned by
case starma it's just wrapping up now
commissioned by Pierre scarmer written
by Gordon Brown it's taken two years and
there are absolutely tons of
recommendations in it and I guess the
big question in this room was it's all
good to talk the talk but will you walk
the walk what were you actually
Implement well the main strands of it is
Devolution about passing power economic
power tax raising power from central
government to local government to the
English mares and also to devolve
governments in Scotland Wales and
Northern Ireland and then of course
constitutional reform lots of questions
about wood care starmer abolish the
House of Lords replace it with an
elected chamber in his first time he
says that's his ambition and but really
the question I think really is how
relevant is this to people struggling
with the cost of living He says we have
to fix the economy to fix the struggles
of everyday lives I wonder how it will
land with a public with far more
pressing demands at the moment
thank you Beth that's it from me for
today I'm very very sorry that the
business news got completely eaten into
by the politicians I'm back tomorrow
morning at 10 o'clock and we'll try
again then stay tuned for the rest of
the business for the rest of the
morning's news after this short break
cheerio
[Music]
[Music]